you once tried to write a song for David
Bowie you sent it to him right I just
had some surgery and I was on pills I
dreamt this song this weird song and
then I woke up and wrote it down
everything and he was in the song and I
said look this I had this weird song and
you're in it do you want to hear it
he said yeah and then I paid him and
then he said he said it's not one of
your best can you believe that I can't
it was wonderful is that wonderful what
is wonderful about David Bowie telling
you it's not one of your best song
because a he was right it was terrible
and B it was just a nice chance to hang
out with him so I wasn't really bothered
about the song do you remember the song
no oh what's your favorite Bowie song
life on Mars would you do a cover
version of that
it's a god-awful small affair to the
girl with the mousy hair
but mommy's heaven no and that it just
told her to go but a friend is nowhere
to be seen now she walks through a song
called room
to the seat with the clearest feel and
she's up to the silver screen
but the film is a saddening boy but
she's lived it 10 times um well it's
about to be ripped again as I asked you
to focus on scene fighting in the dance
hole
look at those cavemen go
it's the freakiest show go look at them
meaning up the road oh man
wonder if you ever lose
is in the best selling show is there
life on my
don't ever done that oh really